Merhaba
merhaba
merhaba dünyanın halkaya olmuş işyeri
geldiklerinde
sevgili
olabilir
[Müzik]
bir yaşam alanı hazırla
alacaksınız mı
[Müzik]
de
İstanbul'dayım İstanbul'dayım
ve orada arttırdım aldık ve İstanbul bir
paketler bir yaşam alanın
hazırlanmasında yine yılan tasarlıyorlar
içerisinde desteklerinizle
oyunlarımızla
Çocuğun
var mı
[Müzik]
ve
toplulukları bir hazır biz buna ve buna
ne kadar oldum da burada yeni 2.014
yılında
yılında bulduğunda
bebeklik ayağa kaldırma gördükten sonra
ne yapacağız
[Müzik]
çocuklar için o
Evet şimdi
Aslında be
alınmış ve ben de yeni bir
bununla ilgili olarak
ilk alındığında adım
hazırlığımızı yapmaya başladı 2013
yılındadır Ben
[Müzik]
şu an
mi Evet bu
ne demek Yani
aslında ilk üç maddesi
insan çip faydalı olur Dua için faydalı
olan
ve bunların içerisinde üretim kaybedip
tekrar insanlığa bakır Böylelikle
farkındaysanız bu çok
sürdürebilmek yemesini gerçek
karşılığını uygulamak mümkün olabiliyor
aynı zamanda olmadı bir türlü
[Müzik]
en geniş görüşlü olalım mı bu anlamda
bunu engellemenin Yolda
çok iyi yani
bütün hepsini kavrayabilecek nasıl
oluşur Bu Şehir Yaşamının modern
sosyal Kooperatifler özellikle
[Müzik]
olabilir mi
bu dünya verdim Çok eğlendik ve birazda
burada
önemsediğimiz ya da anlatacak bir öyle
görselde
gördüğün
bizim yaşamımızda Aslında doğru halini
geçmişte
içinde birşey böyle işlerden kuşlara
bunların dışında
güvelenmesi ne kadar
bir büyük
Aslında bu
bizim atalarımız
köylerinde yaşamışlar
[Müzik]
Oh be çıkmadı Bu da böyle Anladın mı
daha da bir yerde armut aşırı yediğiniz
vardır yerlerde İnsanların bu ayağına
işlerini tekrardan verilmeyebilir
Ya ben
ne oldu bir toplulukla yapabilirsin
gereksinimleri bebekler
işleri olarak birleşik ortaklaşa sahip
oldukları demokratik kurallara göre
içeriklerini program
güzel mi
ve ardından
Evet Eric değerlerimiz içerisinde Aynı
bu
olarak bir ve yeni öldürmüş sünger gibi
çöpten bulduğu sünger gibi bir
mesajı gibi gezmek istiyorum ki mal
bunu yaparken de
yardımlaşma yanında iyi düşünün Sen de
fazla olduğunu
seni kullandım bir de içinde yapmak
istedik ve bu parmak ama Tasarımın ilk
yerlisi Beykoz'da öyle yerleşmesi
yavrular bir yerleştirip
Aslında hepimiz şu
yerleşmesinde şu an 8 yıldır testlerini
yaptığımız durumlarını gördüm
uygulamalarını bu uygulamaların
faydalarını zararlarını ve sorunları
tespit ettiğiniz bu haberin Elime çok
yerine bu örnekler misin
oy verecekler müzikleri gerek motifleri
gerek yavaş şiirler de yavaş kazalardır
bunun benzeri modelleri bu
bütün Türkiye'de Aslında çocuklarımıza
bu eksik olan
parçaları tamamlayacak mı Bir Büyük
Birlik oluşturmak mıyız Öz yerleştirdik
aldık bizim bu tür testler yaptığınız en
önemli fakat havuz ya da Bilecik'te kar
var mı
[Müzik]
O her şehirleşmenin söyle
dua
eksiklerini ailenin
verebileceğiniz
hücrelerimize gideceğim şimdi Çünkü bu
İstanbul Bu anlamda çok büyük meyve çok
büyük sorunları var bu sorunların
karşılayabilmek ki İstanbul
İstanbul'da bulunuyor
Ve çok önemli
hemen hemen ilk dönem yemeklerinden biri
bu ya
[Müzik]
A7 uzaktan başı 20 TL
çok
yerleşmesi sonucu ve ay ediyorum
yükler ağzını kendi kızarsın
insanlar da zaten çok İşte
biz burada hem yani bildiğimiz eve
kalacaktır hem de bu benim fazla mızı ne
yapabiliriz yere uğraşır
Bu gördüğünüz gibi çocuklarımız bize
beraber model dünyanın
bizimle gerçekten biraz farklı
çocukları eğitmek yerine bebeğim sen
olarak
maruz kalmalarını sağlayıp öğrenmeleri
verilmiştir
eğitimler aranızda bunun Aslında nasıl
sonuçlanacağı ile alakalı
çok ciddi olan insanlar var
çocuklar şu anda Herhalde
yaşlarda ve okullarında bizimle beraber
hiçbir şey kalmamış olmalarına rağmen
okulların değil lojik kulüplerin
liderliğini yapanlar var
bu ve bizi şaşırtacak derecede
soğanımızı bilmesi gereklidir nasıl
bakın olması gerekiyor Nasıl olması
gerekiyor böcekleri nasıl davranmamız
gerektiği yerlerde
gözlemler yapmıştır ve bu güzelleştir
arkadaşların anlatıyorlar
ve
günlük yaşamın içerisinde
ve bizim eğitim dediğimiz şey aslında
çocuklara verdiği zararla Aslında Bugün
eğitimin anlar olan faydasını hepinizi
tartısına bırakıyorum bizim evin önünde
geri dönüyorum günlük yaşamımız aşağı
böyle görüşmez günlük olarak kendimize
yardım ederler mesela
da düşünmesi lazım Yardım isteriz
taşıdır elmasının bulunması isteriz
Çünkü
bu ve
bunun yanında
düşündüğünüz
[Müzik]
zaman o
abone ol
Bu bir Anladım olmayan yaşadı verdiniz
İyiki oyun alanları yaratıyor
Zira
[Müzik]
bulunmaz bir nimet
gelmesi için olmuş ve ada yaptığında
herhangi yeni acımadı
zayıflar
bebişim tutmak istiyorum doğal
dikkatli
göre bir vücudunuz dengelemek ve bunlar
için ve
bu ne kadar değer değildir
çocukları
maruz bırakmak istediğiniz bugün alanı
böyleyim
abone ol
Ama bu
ağaçların üzerinde al metre yükseklikte
yan tarafta en niyetleri olmayan bir ara
vermesi yazdım
[Müzik]
sadece oyun alanı nasıl bir sınır renkli
oyun alanlarında önemli görmek için
çocuklar için muhteşem bir değil mi
[Müzik]
çok güzel bir canlı
izle pek
çok
her şeyi konuş ya
[Müzik]
ve yine paketimizden Işık
üretimimiz geliyorum ne kadar bunu
öğretmenlerimiz yapıyoruz bundan
öncesinde peynir ettiklerimizin
gösterdi güçlü üzerinden aldım
ve mesajlarıyla Aslında
Sultan böceklerin resmini ile
etmeden ürünler geliştirme
bir mutfak Bildiğiniz var ufak
birliğimize
Üyeleri ve her birinin cevresindeki 5
aile katıldığı programda uzaylı
bir gıda birimimiz var ve
bütün ailelere paylaşıyoruz kendi Bu da
Evet
Ee bunun yanında ailenin farkında
çalışmalar yapıyor aynı kartları
dediğimiz ve
bunun yanında üretici
faaliyetlerini var
yani yıllık olarak
ihtiyacımız var Türkiyedeki girişimci
öğretmenler siparişi bu iş bilimleri
bizim gözümüzde bu
resimlerinde kafasını karşı ve bu
[Müzik]
burada
yıllık olarak oluşuyor
bu
çocuklar gördüğünüz gibi
dinle
ilgili ayetler bilmiyordum
ne
yapıyor
[Müzik]
hizmeti veriyor Bu
İstanbul'da şehrin ortasında görünüm
için
[Müzik]
yapabiliyor bizim yarattığımız sınıflar
Bu
ip Ban şehrin yerinde başkalarının
yazması gibi bir lüksümüz yok
çocuklarımıza öğretmemiz gerekiyor
çocuklarımızı en kısa sürede Aslında
bunu Zeynep sorumlu almaları gerekiyor
Ama bu
Bu bir öğretmenimizin adı gün yüzden
verdiği şey diye burada bir sınıf
görmüyor olabilirsiniz ama bir
sınıfın kat be kat üstünde verimli olan
bir
besin
öğretmenlerden aldığımız geri dönüşüm
yeni yeni bilgiyi gelirim çok ve ve
çocuklara farklı organlar yarattığınız
onlar da çocukluğunu salgılar bir basit
bir niyetleri bilendir duruyor bu
şartları bu nazlar bunlara vermemiz
gerekiyor Burası dondurma
ortasında da o
Bu
bir oyun hamuru aslında ama aynı zamanda
bu sizin dersiniz onlardan biri gereken
[Müzik]
Bu sınıfta da beni çok yüksek
bu Nehri almaz mısınız bugün yeşilin
geldi fotoğrafıma
ders varsınız Yokluğunda olduğunda
burada
aynı mı
[Müzik]
ve hızlı ayetlerin kutuları
Allah'ın Özeldir bize geliyor biz
bunları alıyorum tekrar Burada yine
üniversitenin Mimarlık Fakültesi vardı
onlarla beraber bir çalışma yapıyoruz
bunların sonucunda bir şey ediyoruz
Bizimkiler de bu Helal olsun onlardan
biri tamamen şube gönderilmiş ve
[Müzik]
sağlıklı mı
Bu videoda girdiğine bir sağlık 100 lira
Tamam lazım
[Müzik]
herkes tarafından yapılabilir
uygulanabilir
paylaşılabilir olmuyor yazıyor
bir şey ve gitme mısınız yerinden koydum
bal kaynatası diye bir şey var benim
olsun
bir şey var
bahsettiğim gibi mesela
kendimizi
Bilecik'te
karşısına bir köylü
Bugün en büyük sorun şu böyle böyle
benim
iki tane geçim var Bu geçici peynir
yapıyorum ama benim aslında aldığımızı
bari nereye satacak mı geliyor ayak
güzel gidiyor Rüzgar
alıyor ve onu satıyorum Fakat bunun
yerine Biz diyoruz ki biz
yöneticiye ürettiği birleştirirsek
karıştırırsak
önceden olabilir o
gözünün resmini de anında
yeni 17 oynayacağım yapabiliriz hiçbir
projenizin 3. yılı ve Biz şu anda
geçip çobanın bırakıp peynirli olmuş
köylümüzün he bakmak geçici şu anda geri
döndük köyde bakıyor ve diğer ürünlerin
üretimi
3B köylü adamı metinleri Ben önceden
organize ettiği
finansman modeli ile biraz ve
düşün ki
[Müzik]
bu işi Garanti Ne bileyim diye
bunlarda
insanları yani konularında
mimarisine şal
örtmeye çalışıyor Çünkü
biliyorsunuz
daha
çok
daha çok mu
[Müzik]
Evet Ee Nur ellerine anne
ekolojik anlamına gelen aileler
çocuklarıyla beraber
orada başı İnşallah takması
çok
[Müzik]
okuyabilirsiniz
bir sürü Can
bütün bir Doğa farkındalığı paylaşım ve
[Müzik]
hem de
tarzımızı bozukluğu oluyor
Ben bugün İnternetten
sürece de çok Bildiğin sürece de aslında
toplum olarak yeşil manage Engine
faydası sürebilir
başka
birisini boyaya başladık
başka bir
mutfakta yemek pişer
teşekkür ediyoruz ve